(uptempo music)
- [Narrator] While canyoneering
is a brand-new sport,
it starts with an
old-school leap of faith.
Its participants hold their
breath as they rappel down
seemingly bottomless canyons formed
by centuries of wind and water.
Through oncoming waterfalls,
around blind turns
and dangling over cliffs,
the sport’s pioneers
take on natural wonders the
rest of us would never dare.
Kitt Turner is one of those pioneers.
He and and his team are
about to enter Canada's
Box Canyon for the first time,
a place that will make their knees quake.
(uptempo music)
- I got started running canyons in Hawaii.
I started rock climbing
and eventually made
the progression into canyoneering.
Jenna's my girlfriend.
She's a Hawaii girl, born and raised.
We've been dating now
for almost two years.
We met climbing.
- Kitt always pushes me to go outside
my comfort level, a lot.
(dramatic music)
- [Kitt] When you're
talking about canyoneering,
the process of descending a canyon,
you have to decide how much
rope you wanna bring along.
You wanna decide if the rock
quality is gonna be good
enough to set up anchors for the rappels.
You also have to find a good crew
that is good under pressure.
- You're just dealing with
lots of complexities of nature.
Rocks, waterfall,
it's just constant problem
solving, using your brain,
using your body.
- Canyons are very fickle,
and they're very weather dependent.
Conditions in a canyon can change
from one day to the next,
from one season to the next.
(upbeat music)
For this particular canyon, Box Canyon,
you have to cross the Squamish River.
- [Jenna] Kayaking across
the river was an ordeal
because you just really have
to paddle your heart out
just to cut across that current.
And then you have to make a sharp U-turn
into this little tiny beachfront.
- [Kitt] So once you cross the river,
there's a mosquito-infested hike
into kind of the bottom
of the Box Canyon stream.
And then you hike upstream for a while
before you get to the
technical part of the canyon,
which involves rope.
- The first thought was, is this man-made?
This is not real.
It looks like a
Disneyland ride.
- One, two, three.
Box Canyon is considered a Class C canyon.
Most of the rappels if not all the rappels
you're going straight
through the water course,
which is straight through the waterfall
and you're getting pounded by the water.
It's hitting you in your face.
You're slipping, you're
sliding all over the place.
- [Jenna] My favorite thing
about dropping into a canyon
is the rush of getting over the edge.
- This is my passion, man.
I don't get more pumped
than when I'm in a canyon.
- [Kitt] It kinda adds
that element of excitement
where you can't see where
you're gonna end up.
(yelling)
- [Jenna] When you're on
the edge as an adventurer,
when you feel like I could
die doing this right now
but I can't back down, and then you do it,
it's like the most amazing feeling.
Woo, yeah.
I don't get the people that are
like, why would you do that?
I'm just like, why not?
If you don't get it, you don't get it.
- For someone who's looking
at doing what we did, which
is dropping everything
and pursuing your dreams,
I would say that it's
definitely a leap of faith.
And maybe you crash and burn,
but the highs are incredible
and you're never gonna get
those amazing moments and see if you
can really achieve your
dreams if you don't try.
(soft music)